live long and prosper
[Music]
Star Trek discovery it is one of the
most highly anticipated shows this fall
Michael how are you feeling right now
I'm grateful humbled a little
overwhelmed we strive toward this dream
of peace where all species can share
common ground we've seen different
iterations of the Star Trek world but
there are so many firsts with Star Trek
discovery the first time we're seeing it
through the eyes of a female through a
first Assessor through of
african-american yes yes a female black
lead an Asian female captain of a female
captain with a female first officer
through the eyes of a first officer
first openly gay character in a TV show
of Star Trek it's it's a lot of persons
we're doing our best to uphold the
legacy to have such an amazingly diverse
cast of care what does that mean to you
to be spearheading it oh my gosh it
means everything to show people what
they really look like to be an actual
mirror to what our society looks like is
a really big deal Michael Burnham
welcome to discover what are you hoping
that women are gonna take away from
tuning into this show I hope that women
see their potential I hope that it sort
of expands you know people's thinking
especially young girls I hope that it
just sort of stretches out the edges of
their parameters we need to do we need
to win that's a spirit walk is such an
iconic character and we do know that
your character Michael has a connection
to the Fox world what they do explain to
the fans out there who maybe are not as
familiar with the connection yes well I
can tell you that my parents died of as
Furnham up here I started a young age
when I was when I was bringing and I it
happened at a Vulcan outpost and so I
was commissioned into the home of
stearic and Amanda who happened to be
Spock's pay raise
so essentially he's my brother now in
the original series Spock didn't
necessarily mentioned that he had a
surrogate sister so I understand though
that you guys are gonna pay homage to
the roasting cannon you tease that will
that answer get revealed I will say that
cannon is very important to us it's
everything it's our foundation and we
definitely honor it I will say that it
will make sense it will make sense
[Music]
you
[Music]